two major foreign policy blow-ups for
president biden
talks between the u.s and china getting
off to a very rocky start
secretary of state anthony blinken
calling china out for human rights
abuses
but china telling the u.s it should look
in its own backyard
a u.s official reportedly accusing china
of grandstanding
and chinese state media they say the
meeting was an embarrassment
for the usa vladimir putin also
mocking president biden after biden said
this
you know vladimir putin you think he's a
killer
i do putin responding by challenging
biden to a quote
live debate the white house saying it's
not going to happen
the president is quote quite busy
sandra uh you know this whole idea of a
biden
putin debate i i'm struck by this
because
what are they going to debate whether
putin is a murderer so it sounds like
putin got his cage rattled here
uh i guess that's one way to look at it
one i mean do you
i guess i could kind of turn that around
and ask you do you think it's healthy
to see this happening on the world stage
so early in biden's presidency i was
talking to
former secretary of state mike pompeo on
our show yesterday
he looked at the exchange after we
played it for him it takes one to no one
and then putin wishing him good health
quipping back
he said it all seems a little bit
childish to him so i think it's
interesting to
see this happening just months into joe
biden's presidency when
you know foreign policy supposed to be
his strongest suit
pompeo's point was focus on america
first we saw that under
the last presidency he pointed out he
wants to see that from from biden he did
give him props however
almost sort of conceding for the killer
remark and agreeing to that
uh he said facts basically point to that
but as far as
meeting with those officials foreign
policy is going to have to be joe
biden's strength that's what he promised
in the campaign
and he's going to be held to that juan
well jesse uh we had intelligence
reports this week
that said that in fact putin tried to
get trump reelected and defeat biden
it looks like he made the wrong bet and
he's going to have a rough four years
with with biden
yeah i don't care that biden called him
a killer and they yanked their
ambassador
putin's always getting upset about
something i care what biden does
if he blocks nordstrom 2 the pipeline
deal between europe
and russia like trump blocked it that's
all that i
care about he's had a rough 24 hours
want even you would have to admit that
russia china mexico the stairs
i mean that video is everywhere him
looking like
i'm not going to say it it's everywhere
it's like the guy
throwing the shoe at w except w
looked agile biden didn't look too agile
there
i understand ford fell down the stairs
too he got mocked for it
he was a great athlete but that was
something that he couldn't really live
down
at least he didn't throw up on the
japanese like bush 41.
we'll give him that but this meeting
they had with the chinese
they're coming to our soil and talking
trash juan
and we let the cameras in why'd we do
that
why did we do that at least donald trump
would have the
dignity and the respect and then behind
the scenes bring in the killers on trade
and turn the screws to the chinese
that's how you play it
china's a paper tiger we hold all the
cards if we want an oil embargo we could
do it
if we want to sanction their guys if we
want to de-list their companies
we could make these guys fall apart in
24 hours but china knows the donors that
installed joe biden want to go back to
normal
and make a killing off all that slave
labor in the mainland
and so they're going to throw it in our
face oh yeah black lives matter
meanwhile china is a killing machine
they killed like ten
tens of millions of their own people in
the last century i'm not even talking
about
forced abortions so they have no right
to come over there and talk trash
i think we hold all the cards
all right so greg uh getting right to
what jesse's just talking about that
china conflict
it's getting hotter and hotter it looks
to me like the u.s is going to have to
increase military preparation
both in cyberspace maybe even an outer
space
we're going to have to say something
about taiwan hong kong
are you even their proxy wars in africa
latin america
is the u.s public really ready for a
21st century cold war with china
i don't know but i do think that i do
think that
the president needs to take some steps
to deal with china
but i don't think he can take steps
uh-oh
so here's the deal i don't blame trump
for what i don't blame what china did
one minute all they did was use the
talking
points of our media and the democrats
against us
how dare they how dare we lecture china
when we slaughter thousands of blacks
every year if you look at the surveys
that's what a lot of people believe
that we slaughter thousands of blacks
every year
because that grossly inaccurate
statistic is
out there when we do when brave
journalists actually look at these
statistics they find that
in terms of unarmed black men that are
killed in custody
under a variety of circumstances it's
about two dozen right
but because of deliberate prop
deliberate profit-seeking networks like
cnn
we have warped the view of americans
about what's going on
and china exploited it so we just got
schooled
on morality by a country that uses slave
labor
and imprisons people based on religious
belief and they did it
by exploiting the dishonest narrative
that networks used to turn a profit
and speaking of warped views just to go
back to the a block the new york times
today
reports uh 79 decline in new covent
cases
since january so that's not leveling off
it's leveling off over the last couple
of weeks anyway
back to you kaylee the uh what will
winning
uh against china look like because i
mean the u.s and the chinese economy
are so intertwined bonds investments
trade
what do you think i mean what are we
what do we you know what's the prospect
well that's a great question i think
look winning used to be
you know a massive trade deal like what
president trump did with china winning
now looks entirely different after a
pandemic that was
unleashed by china which by the way was
not addressed by
uh blinken during that that encounter
and one thing that is just
incredible to me to jesse and greg's
point not only were we lectured by china
but you had the secretary of state say
in front of china
america is not perfect we have mistakes
why are you saying that to a bully
sitting in front of you
as they by the way deny committing
genocide against the uyghurs to jesse's
point the forced abortions for
sterilizations
they deny genocide but in the biden
administration we'll apologize for
america on the world stage
say we're not perfect and by the way
let's also not forget north korea
threatened us
this week too so it was quite a week in
the world of foreign policy
for joe biden thanks kelly